yeah hello and welcome to this video
video that I announce for two days
already and now I'm finally making it I
hope it will work out fine little bit
better here with my my neck pain but uhm
let's see how this video turns out um
the subject is how useful are older
chess books and the example that I'm
using is or the book that I'm looking at
is a real classic it's about the
candidates tournament 1953 by David pong
Stein David Brownstein always have
problems with names that would never be
pronounced correctly in English like
David Bronstein sounds weird but where's
this book I have the German version
really old one this is one book that was
published not published it's probably
the right word I mean the German version
here is from 1991 so this book is close
to 30 years old and yeah 1991 I bought
it right when it was available because
it was a classic and back then the first
time it seems available in German
language if we read the intro here now
this is one of the most famous chess
books of all actually and often cited as
a favorite book of many players or at
least they acknowledge that they think
it's a it's a great book and I think I
also mentioned it once in my perpetual
chest podcast interview that I didn't
early 2017 I think it was
17 I guess yeah and back then I was
mostly thinking about yeah the the
memory that ahead of the book when I was
a kid but honestly those kind of books
you usually have in your library and but
you never look at them really while you
did when you got it when when in my case
when I was a kid
1991 I was okay was 17 but still pretty
fresh in chess I I had maybe a rating of
1900 or maybe 2000 I don't know
something like that and I really liked
the book back then um but this always a
little bit of an influence of a book
being a classic or being popular you
have a different um idea about it if you
know it's a classic um
now um how did I how did I how did I
meet this book again um I actually did
while doing an analysis or analysis is
strong and it didn't dig that deep it I
was looking at this game yet over
against Geller from that candidates
tournament 1953 and I was coming across
this position while researching losses
of world champions so I did a chess
based felt I had a video series once for
the ICC where I looked at losses of
world champions and this is the loss
whoever lost this game together and I
came across this game and I found it
very instructive and after him I looked
at this on my own
I felt hmm why not check him what
Bronstein is saying about this in this
book and then I looked at the analysis
of the game and it was terribly bad it
was just a very bad
she has analysis I was like hmm this is
weird
why didn't he didn't he analyzed this
properly and this made me question the
quality of the analysis of the book and
I didn't really continue with this
thought or that much got other things to
do but then a little bit later I got the
idea okay let's let's check another game
and then I did it together with a chess
student and the analysis was also bad
pretty bad like hmm what is that so it's
a bit odd you know that it's perceived
as such a great book when the analysis
is really a bit strange at times and I
know this sounds odd but I'm going to
show you some examples and the main
point is that I don't actually think we
should just we shouldn't just look at
this with a modern eye in terms of
computers because the engines will
always prove you wrong
this is clearly this was clearly written
before we had any engines so it is clear
that there must be mistakes it's
absolutely clear no matter how good a
player you are how much time you put
into the computer will always show that
you're overlooking something but I still
think that even without an engine the
analysis is a little bit strange at
times and we found mistakes in the book
like in student and I together without
having a look at the computer the
computer later confirmed that we were
right about certain positions and I will
give you those two examples and then I'm
going to just randomly pick a game out
of the book and see what I can do with
it yeah I'm like without the engine and
see okay I feel like here should let it
should see what happens it's a bit of an
experiment
so first let's have a look at the two
examples and compare the commentary that
bronze landed with what is actually
right so the River Geller game we don't
need to look at the whole game I think
the main point is starting here now
let's have a look at this position that
is on the board after move 42 of them
has just played the move Age 3 and let's
have a look at this position we have a
position here material is equal both
sides have six pawns and yeah Queen
Queen rook minor piece it's a materially
eco position then let's have a look at
the strategic features of the position
um I think if you look at this a little
bit more closely you will probably
recognize that if anybody is better it's
probably black
Lex position is mom is a bit more
compact yes got the better pawn
structure white has in particular a very
loose King side like the pawn structure
e to F for h3 looks a little bit odd
there are quite a number of weaknesses
let's say III it's currently covered
well but there's this is weak and it's
all in the vicinity of the King so white
is a little bit weakened him um black um
has nice decentralized pieces and the
bishop here on f6 is currently
protecting the d4 pawn I thought this
was an interesting example here for my
video series back then because the plan
now that Gellar goes form is very nice
he goes king f7 and then will actually
open up the book of course and see what
Bronstein is saying about all this
and we join
yeah we joined here it say he has a
commentary for exactly this position so
King of seven and this is a German
version so I have to translate it now
what what he's saying um
so he says after after adjournment I
mean back then they adjourned the game
on move 40 and would look at it at home
after a German gala changes the position
I'm trying to destroy Hoover's fortress
yeah this is a good explanation White
has essentially some kind of fortress
built up he tries to just block
everything and he says I'm the black
King YAG goes away and
Oh
[Music]
yeah and he says now Hoover didn't
really adjust to the new situation he's
playing - useless King moves this is
true
going back and forth um and then it says
it would have been better to bring the
knight to the to the Queen side
immediately and this is actually a
really really bad annotation because the
plan to bring the knight to the Queen
side is completely entire positional and
very obviously so the problem is we see
that in the game actually white now
brings the knight over to the Queen side
and we see why I like the game black is
nicely tacking away the King on the
Queen side which is completely closed
and then he tries to open up on the King
side while the own King is safely
positioned on the on this side of the
board so even now brings the knight all
the way to b6
and now now the night on b6 is
completely misplaced if you check this
now this is just completely wrong the
night is offside absolutely offside and
doesn't do anything and on the other
hand now white is lacking a crucial
defender on the Kings side if you just
stay on g2 you just stay on g2 from here
it's very difficult to make any headway
with black you should just stay like
over and over just stay and it's
difficult for black to make any headway
like it's better anyway but the
defensive chances are much better if you
have a knight actually offending instead
of being completely off on on b6 I think
this is a weird way to annotate because
it's pretty clear that the knight is bad
on b6 I just don't don't quite get this
but the worst part comes now because
this position and I don't have the
engine on I'm just getting this from
memory the worst part comes here this
position is not very nice for white
because you see that now black is able
to potentially attack f4 three times
yeah all three pieces can attack the
pawn but the knight cannot defend it
anymore
it knives on b6 well they have no
opportunity to defend it but still if
white is now staying put and doesn't do
all that much it's not so easy for black
to win instead you played f5 this move
isn't giving there's no annotation to f5
it's just move without any text to it or
question mark or whatever yeah f5 G
takes Queen takes Queen h6 and now the
threat of Quincy won't check connected
with rook e8 wins the game immediately
this is a completely lost position now
so f5 is a double question mark move and
this is not annotated it's just not
annotated at all and if you look at the
whole text there's not a single there's
no question mark given to any of whites
moves the key mistakes are not
identified bringing the knight to b6 is
just a bad plan and f5 is basically a
blunder it blunders the game away you
can switch
the engine on just to show some some of
the evaluations of the compet you don't
really need the comp to find that out
so let's say here the computer basically
gives everything is equal which is a bit
of habit harsh because it is not so
equal yeah because black black is the
one term to try and it seems that why it
might might hold this with precise play
but it's not a very fun experience but
it's clear that once the night is on b6y
its position is worse because this is
just a piece that's doing nothing on b6
so this position is evaluated as minus
one now I think we get this and whites
King is a little bit insecure f4 is weak
but the thing is even if you lose the
pawn just like that you're not losing
immediately but after f5 takes Queen
takes Queen h6 it's game over the
computer is initially is immediately on
minus three and if you give it more time
it will be even worse I think it's just
the attack is unstoppable and this is
pretty easy to figure out and I really
wonder why this isn't mentioned I mean
Bronstein was obviously a very strong
player and inti didn't you see that I
cannot believe it I sometimes wonder
what this is this is a lack of effort
lack of time in the production I don't
know one thing I do know is this is
impossible in a modern book it's just
impossible those kind of mistakes
because the computer will immediately
point them out it no matter how strong
the authors actually but it really
identify some key moments in the game
and this I think just gives more insight
this commentary is essentially not very
useful it doesn't show why white lost
and this is the planned to bring the
knight to b6 is anti positional and f5
is just a tactic lame let's say
refutable blunder in a way and it's not
it's not mentioned and this is what I
don't really get and what I think is a
problem with some older books they are
not critic
they don't really try to find out why
some somebody lost maybe out of courtesy
I don't know what the reasoning is
because I don't really think that
Bronstein is not able to identify that I
mean that that would be a bit odd this
was the example that I was coming across
some some years ago and then last week
we looked at student and I we looked at
another game from the same book that is
the next one star by arc against caught
off its erm was the coincidence it's
from the same round here on round 17 um
let's have a look at this one and here
we looked at the whole game because we
randomly picked picked it out of the
book because I mean we wanted to look at
something a game that we didn't know
before and beforehand and this is what
we came up with so it was a randomly
picked game and after this game I'm
going to pick another game at random and
see how the annotation what's up and not
only holds up against the engine because
as I mentioned it's it's it's clear that
the engine will find improvements I'm
just trying to improve myself on the
book and I think sometimes is easy to do
so um okay so let's say look at me look
at this game star bear cut off we have a
have an old onion
an old Indian a defense and I'm going to
give you Bronstein's a notation it says
you should be seven the Kings Indian
Bishop should go to g7 and later it gets
repositioned to that square yeah it's
true I'm in the old Indian is a
different opening to the Kings Indian
but I think it's essentially not wrong
that the bishop would be better on g7 so
and we have castles Quincy - rookie 8b3
and he says yeah this is not a great
development um it would be better to
play rook e1 and maybe later
put the bishop to h3 I'm abbreviating
this a little bit um and it's the
translation is kind of a and of an
effort here so I think he's right yeah
Bishop to b2 is not the best way to
develop but okay it's not it's not a big
deal that same black plays Bishop f8 it
should be two and now the next moves by
black are not annotated I find this a
bit curious because I think it would
deserve something to annotate black now
played Knight h5 and move that I was
really like what really night to h5
what's the deal um it's me it's probably
not so bad
actually then the bishop is now on b2
and the night might jump to f4 okay I'm
but it's not annotated on white not
played g3 um that is a pretty normal
move that you can play you're just
stopping any Knight f4 um g6 black goes
for Bishop g7 later okay
Rock d1
Knight goes back to f6 okay and now
white played the most d5 that's I think
is an interesting decision um and he
says now the position gets a typical
Kings Indian structure why does not want
to allow it takes deform and advances
the pawn so a most less describes what's
going on it's not an evaluation mm and
this is something that's pretty typical
that they often in those older books
they would just describe what's going on
but they would not actually evaluate the
position um so if we do that if you
evaluate the position I think it should
be pretty clear that right must be
better White has a pretty strong space
advantage and white um also doesn't have
to fear much counter player black
because he's essentially playing a Kings
Indian with a couple of Tempe down yeah
he played but should be seven back to F
a droopy eight the rook is wrong on ei
it for example for the f5 push so blacks
only counter play here would be f5 and
it takes ages to get there um yeah the
next move is also not annotated and it's
it's just a bad move black now plays c5
and this is very pretty obvious bad move
like now close the position completely
entered pretty much says okay I will not
have any counter play ever yeah
if black instead and this is what we
were thinking when we looked at the game
black should probably be a bit more
flexible here in the center seeing that
white is not really threatening to take
on c6 if you could play something like a
five or maybe a six something I gotta
keep the tension a little bit and maybe
in on a good day you can take on d5 and
play b5 which should be seven for a
little bit of counter play it's already
very difficult this position because you
don't really have any compensation for
your lack of space where c5 is not
entertaining at all
now after c5
next couple of moves are not annotated
and I mean you you could do that for
sure because some of them in louvers are
a little bit mysterious night aged form
yeah
you can do that oftentimes this is
played in such a structure to prevent f5
altogether but here black is not nearly
threatening this at all I mean it takes
ages for black to threaten that so it's
not quite clear that the bishop belongs
there um in fact we see all these all
these museum and I'm not they're a
little bit mysterious then sometimes
rook f8 black is ultimately preparing f5
nighty to Bishop d7 Bishop C 398
ultimately f5 is what black wants to do
and we're going to join the Entertainer
Bishop FL it's a bit all their Bishop c3
Bishop a5 this all this is not annotated
at all um rupee one
okay back to the tomb Queen back to the
aides Bishop f6 okay the night goes back
up to e7
Bishop h6
7.now and now Bronstein commentates
cutoff that is black right cut of is
black has used the last 10 moves yeah
more favorably and has positioned his
forces very harmoniously yeah that kind
of indicates to me that Bronstein things
black has a good position and I don't
know blacks position is not good it's
absolutely not good I mean if we check
what what happened in the game and again
this is not annotated h4 was played like
play now f5
takes takes Knight c3
and I just want to get to
[Music]
get to this position and this is now
this is the craziest part of this whole
annotation now in this position just
have a look at this the situation here
white still has an advantage in space
with f5 black has weakened his position
more than anything else and he has
absolutely no counter play I mean black
has no counter play here and if white
plays just something normal I mean and
there are a couple of moves that you
could play but the most normal mafia
would be a standard F form and putting
pressure on on black some on black
spawns here for example after E for you
can play 93 and you can prepare g4 and
this position is just for a human eye
you don't need a computer it's just
better for white and if you switch on
the engine it will be pretty radical I
didn't expect that it was clear to me
when I looked at this with with my
student that like white is pretty
substantially better I mean of course he
is but if you switch on the engine
it's like plus 2 it's just devastating
and the engine even likes g4 more which
is not a very standard way to do it yeah
we were more thinking about f4 in this
position again without a computer and
also this is a huge advantage you have
to see that in a position like that
white will play G form and this can be
absolutely devastating if you check this
the position now opens up in White's
favor this of course takes yeah you have
to look at this a little bit but it is
very clear that white is much better
here
much better you have g4 as well as an
idea and an important point is that
black can never snatch this here if you
look at this
Queen gets trapped it's a nice little
point but it's of course white is better
and you can absolutely not stay in this
position that black has maneuvered more
successfully blacks position is terrible
I mean the computer gives all kinds of
things that are great for white but even
if you just do nothing with white you're
much better because black has only one
player's f5 and that weakens so why does
clearly for choice M clearly and now we
get to this position here when white is
clearly better and now white plays the
unbelievably bad move Bishop takes you
seven I mean I really I don't get this
at all Bishop takes you seven I mean
what you give up the most important
bishop that you have on aged six again
sad miserable night for what reason this
is just a really bad for somebody was
playing in a candidates tournament I
mean this is not really him to salute
that I know it's just terrible
it makes absolutely no sense and this
this move gives away all the advantage
like everything and it's not not
mentioned it's just like just to move
like know what no annotation no question
mark no no texts nothing and it's an
obviously terrible move so sometimes I
read review of the book just before I
made the video and I said the book would
be great also because it would address a
large range of playing strength like it
would explain um some key points also to
not so strong players yeah but please
Bishop takes you seven is totally that's
just terrible and you have to mention
that well and and it's obvious also to
play like Bronstein that is terrible
move why isn't it annotated I don't I
don't get this so this is just weird and
then we continue a little bit
till this move a form the eform and he
says some yeah this is a good idea to
activate the night this is a notation
I'm fine with and the next one is kind
of interesting but we have night F form
rook e8 and here Knight takes c6 was
played so black is offering the exchange
and white is taking it yeah white
actually misses a tactical short that
Braunstein also misses this is something
that my student I also missed white can
simply take on e4 and it's better here
and if you look at this more deeper with
the engine this will go up it's just a
tactical the tactical strike you just
give up the the knight first and then
win the exchange and the resulting
position is pretty clearly better for
white this was also missed in the
annotation and this is the kind of thing
that I always think okay that can happen
right you don't have the engine at the
time they didn't have it and you can
just miss a move like Knight takes e4 it
happens but what I don't get is such an
obvious strategic mistake as Bishop
takes you seven you have to annotate you
cannot just let it stand there this
changes the game completely if white
plays something good shape you will just
wipe out black and after Bishop g7 black
us better or I mean the computer doesn't
even say black is better but it's just
it's just so bad to do it so here
there's a tactical mistake which again I
completely understand that this is made
um and after that actually the
annotation is fine
I don't really we didn't really have any
objection to this yeah it's actually
it's a pretty interesting game and I
don't want to look at this in in March
depth I just want to point out one
interesting moment that's really really
strong player black yeah in this
position after we need three here black
played very nice move King to g6 did you
get there a little bit by elimination
but it's very nice white is threatening
this and threatening the bishop and
black can just simply play king g6
because after Queen take
intakes h7 there is the medium yeah this
it's very nice it's a very aesthetic
aesthetic way to claim and yeah in them
in the game
black ultimately won in the ending and
there the annotation is fine we didn't
find any any mistake there so the thing
that I don't get is that they're obvious
strategic mistakes are not annotated I'm
not saying yeah you know you should see
all the tactics this is of course not
possible but Bishop takes you seven
please or getting the knight to be six
which is completely anti positional that
has to be annotated and it's actually
instructive it's really instructive and
it is not it's not there and I'm
completely sure like if you take any any
modern book on strategy or annotated
games they would have those moves and
attain it absolutely 100%
simply of course the engine will point
them out this would be of course a huge
shell but even just a human player
looking at them a modern Grandmaster or
in my case and I am would spot those so
let's look at a third game and this is
now basically a live experiment I'm just
going to randomly select the game I have
a random number generator and I will
generate a round number round number two
so I'm going to pick a game from round
two ideally one that I don't know
because then it would be a little bit I
just want to have a fresh look at a game
that I don't know that is annotated so
okay this is not so great gala movie is
a very famous game
and
[Music]
there yeah this is the thing sometimes
the games are all very famous now this
one I don't know Braunstein night off
okay let's do this I'm going to get this
the other two games in round 2 are so
famous that I'm that this kind of makes
no sense if I look at them because I
just know the games and then know what's
going on there so Braunstein over from
round two is that one too
um I guess right
know that London everyone's teen idol
I'm sorry
on this
a bit of a Messier on now let's let's
have a look at this a chapter
now I'm just going to look at this
without the engine and check the
annotations yeah so we have a King's
Indian yeah this is of course all this
is these are the early days of the Kings
in here that's all pioneering work so I
have a coffee actually here so we have
got a form is six
Bishop g5 played by Bronstein yeah this
is a little bit rare this line and it's
not really mentioned much you know it's
not much mentioned here um
image 55 is not played much nowadays
because aged six your bishop either gets
sidelined on age four which is
undesirable or Bishop III mm it's it by
an IG form um yeah it's a bit of a rare
line but okay this is not the point we
have c-51 in Benoni structure
ignite a six so what does Francine same
the annotation is actually pretty brief
yeah but okay we'll see he says I'm only
six moves have been played but they're
already many things happened in that
time I'm right played Bishop g5 and this
provoked black play with c5 yeah maybe
um after d5 black didn't have the
natural square c6 for the night and
therefore night off goes for the night
to c7 root in order to play a six b5
later this costs a lot of time and the
result does not really seem too great
compared to the effort spent the night
on c7 is passive and doesn't do all that
much ultimately it almost cost like the
game okay this is a really good
annotation yeah the night this is
actually I'm often seen the night coming
to c7 trying to prepare b5 and I agree
quite often this is not actually that
fantastic um you would probably nowadays
if you are in this position just Castle
and now it's not clear what white is
doing probably Queen d2 and black
probably goes is 6 for modern benoni
transposition or maybe in some cases you
can play b5 for Benko style play he 6 is
the most normal stuff ok night a6
and wide now this is not a notated
played Bishop d3 yep
97 92 now played
I would probably prefer Knight f3 setups
but this is not a bad move of course a6
a form
would be eight yeah
[ __ ] castles weensy to Bishop d7 and
right now plays h3
a ch3 and allows b5
so white is basically saying he doesn't
annotate it at all
if five
now f4 and now it says
[Music]
Lex piece placement was supporting b5
true white
gets more space which is not compensated
by the b5 pawn
like it's very cramped and we should for
example compare the rukon f/8 with the
rook on f1 yeah that's a good annotation
and the rook on f1 is potentially
stronger of course then they have a
drogue if you see f4 wide might play at
five he might play e5 and all those
cases the rook is active still I wonder
why isn't the f5 also good it's more of
a standard way to do this
so after let's say b5 we take rook
checks and we would probably
successfully claim that white is better
here as well one thing is he however you
are not this is not ideal the position
like that would be really good if we
would have b3 Bishop C to covering b3
very safely and then continue on the
kingside it's it's probably worth
mentioning that a5 is a good alternative
however after b5 white is keeping the
tension and now it seems that black
doesn't really have anything great
available on the other hand
yeah
why it is probably better in both cases
some but you could argue I mean if black
is taking this now which she didn't I
didn't do that right now I played nighty
aid like takes this
it's not
well isn't that a verse version of the
[Music]
of the line before like I have to take
now I guess
yeah group perform and I don't think II
5 or something works Amir Lisa takes
here
isn't that a verse version of this
Rodya probably does
that's not tactic right let me check
this
because here b2 is slightly vulnerable
yeah you have to I mean I'm just no I'm
just
in this there's no tactics right SB to
always say something happening on be to
know
don't think so
I still think I would prefer a 5-2 h3
ultimately okay nighty aids I'm not sure
if this is a good idea 98 and now white
takes on b5
and goes rook a seven
yeah whites position looks pretty good
hey take steaks
Ruka 8 he says white black cannot allow
f2a 1 and white is now trading the only
active black piece that's true yeah this
position must be pretty good for white
huh I guess we didn't really learn what
blacks mistake was now maybe night a6 is
what the author's implicating that this
whole plan is bad yeah it's probably not
great
we'll be three
okay and now f6
black is not black can cannot keep the
Queen forever to cover 7 and therefore
is going to please playing this kind of
yeah it says a tough decision to play f6
which is a nice way to put it yeah if
you have to play of 6 things are really
not going your way
so Bishop age 4 will be 6
and queen a3
Wow the most amazing thing is that this
is ending in a draw interesting it looks
completely terrible for black
okay Queen a3
nights his 7b three
now night see 75
okay
up here and now f5
you
it's a pretty long annotation
he says the whites advantage which is
kind of piling up as he says have become
pretty enormous and white now tries to
with f5 to improve his position
decisively now Knight f4 is a threat
you
they don't understand the annotation
he mentioned that White has the idea
Bishop II one as well
okay and that rook a1 was also an
interesting move
yeah ff5 is not so easy to play because
you of course have many upsides of this
move but on the other hand you also give
black this diagonal
mmm the tough one he also mentioned Rukh
a one
as f-5e five doesn't work yeah so he
mentioned this one rook a 1f v e5 yeah
the point is that here you probably ft6
check right here d6 check
you
exchange I wonder what happens here
batik
probably can take this one right yeah
okay then that should win he only has
King H ad is 6 cm okay rook rook rook a1
looks like a strong move of course
this-this-this feels actually that like
f5 is not really necessary
if you play rook a one Queen a seven or
something like that or Queen a five you
should be really really tremendously
better
I said probably many things are a good
year Hawaii yeah that's a tough call I
mean I know don't I don't want to look
at this super super deep f5 yeah
probably it's probably so good
so Bishop age six
take sandy five so what is going for for
the throat
the sting
of black has taken
23
you
yeah bees as wide now plans 93 rupee one
trying to enter under on the queenside
this is all possible because the night
is so bad on a yeah that's definitely
true
King edge 793 queen bee 3 will be 3
okay
you
he said he just goes back and says
instead of queen d3 we should f2 was
stronger
Bishop F - Roxy AIDS
I mean dr3 king g 7h form that looks bad
yeah idea being age five and then night
xiii to get on the light squares that's
it makes a lot of sense
now it is indeed much better
okay so queen bee three
and now it says yeah now black has the
the chance to trade Queens with which
helps the defense yeah it's probably
true rupee one reform
you
he says white of course does not take
the pawn allowing the Black Knight to
escape
it isn't this position still terrible
effect hey this looks really really bad
you
all right this is this is really really
weird now look p8
after the root rate is as now White's
advantage is disappearing almost
completely it was better to take on e7
but all in all now he goes back this is
this is really odd and he says instead
of king f3 this is annotated on move 34
but you know it goes back it says
instead of king f3 white should have
played
she should play this move to get rid of
the bishop okay
it makes sense
that deposition is so terrible for black
the engine gives you it looks completely
completely lost actually have you
imagined this this is never moving this
is absolutely never moving
yeah you can play in 95 shortly I mean
okay you have to stop the porn of course
but then not be 5 it never moves it's
never moves okay in the game route
piayed and now he says rook takes his 7
was was better and after this it's
supposed to be equal
right a form
have you take on c5 at the end c4 will
fall so if you take him he doesn't give
anything anymore like this this lose the
c4 so King III 90 c7
and TM draw us agreed
probably probably okay so this
annotation is quite a bit better than
the ones before I think probably if you
switch on the engine it will find many
improvements but again this is not my
point
here I think he clearly points out some
key moments like for example that here
bishop g3 was strong but okay we'd
switch on the thing and see what what
the engine has to say about it so let's
go here and and see um yeah so here 85
would be my preference quite clearly
which is also mentioned by the comp yeah
now it takes a while but then a degrees
plus one is with a five and h3 is also
like so yeah I wasn't quite sure I think
I would have played a five but this
position also looks good F form and here
I think I thought maybe B takes a four
would be better um
98 is an odd move
this is probably
[Music]
probably the same thing as before yeah
it's just it's better a good with the
plus-one evaluation
okay a formed 98
now we've got this Andrew a seven
okay eight
this is great yeah now this f6 move him
I agree this is a very tough decision
but maybe black black doesn't really
have much better
I mean how I ever going to move the
Queen is it's really true so f6 Bishop
age form will be six Queen a 397
v3
tonight b5 yeah so the computer is
actually not disliking blacks position
all that much
so Knight takes bishop takes and now f5
yeah I'm sure I really think this I
would have probably played rook a 1 and
this is preferred by the comp I'm not
I'm not such a clear fan of f5 on a
steam
so Bishop age six which is disliked
computer response to play 97 and get
this back into the game
yeah make sense the night is what could
on a eight this is probably the problem
but this is probably exactly the game
yeah if I've looks strong
that's a nice move takes takes D takes
and ta said Bishop f2 was stronger which
is not exactly what the engine is giving
but it's getting them now it's now it's
a favorable the favorite move of the
comp it makes a lot of sense never
should have to Queen d3 King edge 793
and now 97 is better than kriby 3 which
is not really as surprising the night
should really move away now 97 now is
better than win be 3
and now we get
we get to this position
there will be seven
so ultimately then design notation is a
little bit strange because it says
Black's defense is easin by the Queen
trade which is not really true I think
but okay King g8 here Bishop f4 is
favored
yeah that makes quite a bit of sense if
you just see you're in okay this is
hanging with the check there for
difficult decision but it's probably
more important to get this get this
active
if you look at the game after King g8 we
we had this and now Bishop Bishop g3s as
pointed out by Bronstein probably a
winner this position is just so terrible
white is just getting closer to the pawn
and has night be five this is just awful
really awful
and now here what I wondered was if
white is not still able to post more
problems here
it doesn't really annotate this anymore
this night a forum yeah if the King I
mean this should still be a bit better
because White has a much better pawn
structure it's probably not going to be
anything decisive like this let's say
this and what's the engine gives you
this is kind of a and of a fortress we
would widest of course still able to
post problems this would be a nightmare
against a strong technical player we
should f2 comes here as always tying
blacks defenses to c5
still not much fun
so we randomly picked this game and this
annotation is quite a bit better than
the one the two the two that I've saw
that I've seen before and this is a
little bit yeah it's actually a little
bit a bit bit of a positive note because
I couldn't really think that every
single game is annotated in that bad
fashion as the first two but what I'm
getting at is that if you have those
older books then they have instructional
value but they also have a couple of
pretty pretty weird annotations not
pointing out some of the I think
important important effectors so
compared to modern books they are if you
take a modern book on strategy they are
just a lot better yeah they are better
better research normally and the
computer just helps tremendously
important out resources and finding key
moments of the games for example if you
take if you look at a strategy book if
you take a modern book for example by
Boris Gelfand the strategic
decision-making in chess and on its
positional I think positional
decision-making in chest um this is some
like miles better simply because of yeah
much yeah it's it's much more precise
and also the key points key decisions
they're more clearly explained so those
books are still having some value but
take it with a grain of salt some of
those evaluations we now nowadays know
some some things a little bit better and
the the technology helps to yeah show to
show the mistakes better and the key
moments of the games um if you have this
book Zurich 53 you might have it it's
it's yeah very well-known book um it's
not a bad thing to go through it and
check some of those games because the
games are really very very interesting
and then maybe do it a little bit like I
did with a little more bit more time I
didn't want to look at this now for for
two hours if you have time
check the annotations make up your own
what you think about them what you think
could be interesting and at the end do
we do it this luck I did so check it
with the computer it will give you even
a new perspective and this is a good way
yet to learn about all parts of chess
and it's kind of quite interesting it's
this has a little bit of a detective
flare to it yeah trying to find out what
did he get right what didn't he get
right yeah at the end we will just be
yeah we have learned something at the
end I hope you enjoyed the video and
I'll be back tomorrow probably with some
more blitz chest he then managed
tomorrow will be very busy thanks a lot
for watching
you